A split stance.
Rotational row.
Feed one handle through the other and then pull.
Make sure it's tight.
Split the stance
where your toe is in line with the front heel.
You're gonna go ahead and dip down,
drop the hips,
and then lengthen out the arm
so the hips are still engaged.
You're gonna rotate the body,
but don't rotate the feet out.
So now we're disassociating the hips from the spine.
We're gonna rotate the body, reach.
Keeping everything tight here.
The adductors are on
on the backside.
So as I go to rotate and reach up,
we're gonna pull,
squeeze the backside glute into hip extension,
and then pull through.
We reach, pull through.
Make sure that you're getting in the hip extension.
You're driving off the backside leg,
pulling with the lat,
and reaching with the opposite arm.
Back down, rotate.
Use the obliques.
From here, you're going to drive the hip through.
Pull and reach.
Come down, rotate.
Keep the knees in line.
Feet are in line.
Rotate and reach.
Backside glute is engaged.
We're locking out the hip.